WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JOE BIDEN WANTS YOU TO KNOW HE
HAD A YEAR AND A HALF IN
DEVELOPED A MILD CURIOSITY ABOUT
WHERE THE PANDEMIC CAME FROM.
THE VIRUS PROBABLY DIDN'T
ORIGINATE IN OMAHA.
HE PUT HIS TOP SLEUTHS ON IT AND
THEY HAVE PROGRAMSED TO REPORT
BACK AT SOME POINT.
AS OF TODAY TWO-THIRDS OF JOE
BIDEN'S SPIES BELIEVE THE VIRUS
JUMP NATURALLY TO HUMAN BEINGS
FROM INFECTED ANIMALS.
THE SPIES WHO BELIEVE THAT HAVE
NEVER SPOKEN TO WORKING
VIROLOGIST AND DON'T HAVE
INTERNET ACCESS.
THE OTHER THIRD JOE BIDEN TOLD
US LEAN-TO THE THEORY THAT
COVID-19 ESCAPED FROM A
GOVERNMENT LAB IN WUHAN THAT WAS
CONDUCTING DANGEROUS EXPERIMENTS
ON BAT CORONAVIRUSES.
WHO KNOWS REALLY?
EITHER WAY, JOE BIDEN EXPLAINED
WE WILL GET SOME ANSWERS OR MORE
QUESTIONS POSSIBLY SEVERAL
MONTHS FROM NOW.
REST ASSURED THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ON.
WE DOUBTED THAT.
JUST HOURS BEFORE JOE BIDEN'S
ANNOUNCEMENT WE LEARNED THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE SHUT DOWN A LARGE
ON-GOING AND LEGITIMATE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
IT HAD BEEN GOING ON FOR MONTHS.
IT WAS CONDUCTED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S BUREAU OF ARMS
CONTROL VERIFICATION AND
COMPLIANCE.
THEY ENSURE COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA
ARE NOT STOCKPILING BIO- WEAPONS
LIKE BAT CORONAVIRUSES THAT ARE
BE EXPERIMENTED WITH IN LABS.
WHY DID THE WHITE HOUSE SHUT
DOWN THAT ON-GOING
INVESTIGATION?
SENIOR OFFICIALS AT THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH INCLUDING
DR. FAUCI SAID THEY HAD NO IDEA
WHY IT WAS SHUT DOWN.
THAT SEEMED ODD.
THEY ARE CLOSELY LINKED TO THE
STORY.
IT WAS THROUGH NIH THAT FUNDED
SOME OF THAT RESEARCH AT THE
WUHAN LABORATORY.
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY ASKED ALL
OF THESE QUESTIONS.
>> WHY DID YOU GUYS AND LADIES,
WHY DID YOU SPIKE THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION'S INVESTIGATION
INTO THE ORIGINS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND WHETHER IT COULD
HAVE COME OUT OF THE WUHAN LAB?
>> SIR, WE DID NOT SPIKE
ANYTHING.
I AM NOT SURE WHAT YOU MEAN BY
SPIKE.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT SPIKED
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION'S
STUDY.
>> THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
HEALTH.
>> THEY DIDN'T CONSULT WITH
Y'ALL?
>> THEY DID NOT.
>> I READ ABOUT IT IF THE PRESS.
>> DOC, THEY SPIKED IT WITHOUT
TALKING TO EXPERTS?
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO ANSWER THAT
ONE, DO YOU?
>> Tucker: NO.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHY THE
WHITE HOUSE ENDED A MONTH LONG
INVESTIGATION.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
INVESTIGATION FOUND BEFORE IT
WAS CLOSED.
WE HAVE SOME IDEAS.
A FACT SHEET RELEASED BY THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION WRITTEN BY
SOME OF THE PEOPLE DOING THE
SAME INVESTIGATION THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SHUT DOWN
TOLD US RESEARCHERS AT THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY BECAME
SERIOUSLY ILL IN THE FALL OF
2019.
3 WENT TO THE HOSPITAL.
THAT CAME OUT IN JANUARY.
INTEL CONFIRMED IT.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT CONTRACTOR
WHO LED THAT PROBE REITERATED
BASED ON THAT INVESTIGATION'S
FINDINGS SO FAR:
THERE IS PROBABLY CAUSE FOR DEEP
SUSPICION THAT THE VIRUS SKIPPED
-- ESCAPED FROM WUHAN.
POWERFUL FORCES DIDN'T WANT TO
KNOW MORE.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE
INVESTIGATION.
WHOSE SIDE ARE THEY ON?
AND DAVID ASHER IS WONDERING THE
SAME THING.
QUOTE.
SOME COLLEAGUES PLAYED DOWN THE
POSSIBLE LINKS TO CHINA'S
BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS PROGRAMS.
AND:
THAT'S A REFERENCE TO THE MONEY
THAT THE U.S. WENT THROUGH NIH
TO THE WUHAN LAB TO DO RESEARCH
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN CONNECTED TO
THIS PANDEMIC.
DAVID NAMED CHRIS FORD.
THE FORMER ACT THE UNDER-
SECRETARY IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AS SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T
WANT TO DWELVE INTO THE
POTENTIAL OF A LAB RELEASED AND
ONE RELATED TO A CLASSIFIED
CHINESE MILITARY PROGRAM.
WHY WOULD AN OFFICIAL IN THE
U.S. NOT WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
A FOREIGN ADVERSARY VIOLATING
INTERNATIONAL LAW AND IMPERILING
THE LIVES OF MILLIONS?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
HE SAID HE HAD PROCEDURAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROBE AND
INCLUDING HE WAS KEPT OUT OF THE
LOOP UNTIL DECEMBER.
BUT HE SAID THE LAB WORK THEORY
IS VERY POSSIBLE AND CHINA MUST
BE HELD TO ACCOUNT.
IT'S CRITICAL TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
THAT'S HIS POSITION NOW.
IT IT SHOULD BE THE POSITION OF
EVERYONE IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
IT'S THE POSITION OF THE U.S.
MEDIA.
EVERY NEWS ORGANIZATION HAS
UPDATED ITS LIES ABOUT THE
STORY.
THEY TOLD YOU IT WAS A
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
NOW THEY PRETEND THEY DIDN'T
SAY.
THAT EVEN DR. FAUCI REVISED HIS
STATEMENT.
CALLED IT OUTRAGEOUS.
NOW DR. FAUCI ADMITTED HE HAS NO
IDEA WHAT KIND OF RESEARCH WAS
GOING ON IN WUHAN.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY DIDN'T
LIE TO YOU AND USE THE MONEY FOR
RESEARCH ANYWAY?
>> WELL, WE HAVE SEEN THE
RESULTS OF THE EXPERIMENTS THAT
WERE DONE AND THAT THE VIRUSS
THEY STUDIED ARE ON PUBLIC
DATABASES NOW.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY DIDN'T
DO THE RESEARCH AND NOT PUT IT
ON THEIR WEBSITE?
>> THERE NO WAY OF GUARANTEEING
THAT.
>> Tucker: SO DR. FAUCI WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE SAID WE CAN BE
CERTAIN NO U.S. TAX DOLLARS WENT
TO EXPERIMENTS BECAUSE THE
CHINESE DIDN'T WRITE ABOUT IT ON
THE INTERNET, WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE.
WHEN PRESSED BY ONE OF THE FEW
SENATORS WHO IS NOT BRAIN DEAD
DR. FAUCI ADMITTED HE HAS NO
IDEA WHAT THE DOLLARS WENT TO.
WHICH EXPERIMENT THEY FUNDED IN
WUHAN.
EITHER WAY, THIS IS A TOTAL
REVISION OF DR. FAUCI'S
POSITION.
A FEW DAYS AGO HE WAS OUTRAGED
BY THE SUGGESTION HE FUNDED GAIN
OF FUNCTION EXPERIMENTS IN
CHINAA.
NOW HE IS CONCEDING IT'S
POSSIBLE.
HE'S ALWAYS KNOWN IT WAS
THE GRANT DR. FAUCI APPROVED FOR
RESEARCH SUPPORTS THESE
EXPERIMENTS.
A PROTECT UNDERSTANDING THE RISK
OF BAT CORONAVIRUSES AND THAT
WAS OVERSEEN BY PETER WHO TOLD
THE WORLD IN HIGH VOLUME THERE
IS NO CHANCE THIS VIRUS ESCAPED
THE LAB AND WAS APPOINTED BY THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO
INVESTIGATE COVID AND DECLARE
THE WUHAN LAB BLAMELESS.
WHAT A SCAM?
THE GRANT FROM DR. FAUCI SAID IT
WILL FUND TESTING CORONAVIRUS
USING REVERSE GENETICS AND:
OH!
ACTUALLY THAT'S QUITE A BROAD
RANGE.
RUN THAT BY ANY SCIENTIST AND
THEY WILL TELL YOU A LOT FITS
UNDER THAT DESCRIPTION.
WHAT DID THOSE VIRUS INFECTIONS
EXPERIMENTS WITH BAT
CORONAVIRUSES CONSIST OF?
WE DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE THE RESULTS ARE ALL AROUND
US.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTS YOU TO
CALM DOWN.
THEY WANT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS.
IF YOU CAN'T TRUST THEM, W